on doit protéger notre planète préservez
la nature et tous ses habitants
arrêtez de polluer est épuisé leur
souffle
et moi comment je peux faire pour
changer tout cela
et si j'avais eu ce pouvoir et ce
pouvoir
il est entre mes mains en utilisant
celle son plein je peux baisser ma
consommation d'électricité de 4%
et bientôt nous serons 70 collégiens
comme moi à avoir ce pouvoir
le département de la réunion et edf
s'engage auprès des 70 collégiens
réunionnais en distribuant à chacun un
coffret de cils en pleine affaire
installés chez eux par leurs parents et
pour soutenir ce geste tournée vers le
développement durable
le département changera l'ensemble des
lampes sur les 83 collèges d'ici la fin
de l'année scolaire
ensemble nous participons à la
transition énergétique de la réunion
ensemble nous préservons notre